professor why don't you go over what
american cosmic is and i believe you
said that you have
changed from being a non-believer in the
quote-unquote phenomenon to taking more
of a stance of an agnostic believer so
what's responsible for that change
sure
so i started the research into this i'm
a professor of religious studies and um
just to give your listeners an
understanding of what we do in religious
studies because a lot of people think
we're like ministers and stuff we're not
so we're academics and scholars and it's
an interdisciplinary field so we come at
religion with um
different tools like art basically
archaeology sociology history you know
whatever we can use to understand
the impact and effects of religion on
populations
and um
i my field has been catholic history and
looking at
basically catholic history right um
european catholic history when you say
catholic history here's another thing
that your listeners should know is that
that's huge you know there are billions
of catholics all over the world and so
you know one person can't know all of
that history so we focus as well so
we're really focused generally um i've
been looking at extraordinary
things within catholic history and in
catholic history there are saints who
are said to have levitated
and bilocated and things like that so
i've been looking at that i've been
looking at dogmas in catholic history
how dogmas of religion are formed and
then go away and so these are the things
that i've been doing
almost my whole life and um
certainly as a professor
so
um after writing a book about the dogma
of purgatory which is a belief in
catholicism which is a place where souls
go after they die they don't go to hell
but they also don't go to heaven so they
go to this place called purgatory where
they purge their sins supposedly and
then you know then um they're one with
god so this is a belief that ran a
practice that was within catholic
history for a long time so i did a
survey of this and
um
you're right i was an atheist with
respect to ufos um never thought of them
never believed in them
i was
as many people were
and i
on the edge of scoffing at people who
said oh i saw a ufo you know it's like
right you really saw a ufo and so
um
so no i never ever thought i would be
doing this kind of study and but what
happened was that in 2011 and 2012 i i
had been finished with this book and
moving on to some new research in
catholic history obviously but what i
had was i had been going through
archives which are really old libraries
of things from like hundreds of years
ago and i'd been putting together
basically reports um catholics have
always taken great notes and they have
records and
um they have chronicles and things like
that from a thousand years ago or more
and so i'd been looking at these
and i was um making an uh a note
basically of things that i couldn't
really fit into
basically that were strange in my
opinion i thought what are these things
so we're talking about words of light
things that are aerial phenomena um orbs
that that penetrate walls um
you know things that uh like move like
houses in the air you know these kinds
of reports and the people that were
making these reports today we'd call
them like reliable witnesses you know
they were usually um part of the
catholic hierarchy they were
nuns or brothers you know scholars
people like this mayors of towns